[MUSIC PLAYING]
- This is in no way going
to encompass my practice.
This is going to
talk specifically
about this one sort
of large-scale project
I'm in the middle of.
And yeah, let's go.
OK, so negative space, so I want
to talk a little bit about what
I mean when I say that word.
Negative space, as it's
typically understood,
is a formal or art term
that is the space between,
under, around, inside an
object or subject of interest.
It is the atmosphere, unseen
matter, the non-event.
Positive space is
the subject object,
the thing around which we orient
our understanding of what is,
and thereby, what isn't.
So this sets up a kind of binary
that I find really problematic,
where you have this sort
of shapeless absence
as the negative,
and the occupation,
or defined space,
as the positive.
As with any binary, I'm
interested in removing
the primary.
I don't think binaries are
inherently problematic.
It's the imbalance of
power within a binary
that I am always kind of
interested in undoing.
So my reading on negative space
is that it has its own agency,
that it is unfixed.
It's dynamic, changeable,
and ultimately,
free to form and reform.
So I find negative space
to be really exciting.
Because the positive
space is kind of stuck.
And the negative space
is the thing that
has the most potential, really.
So this is the reason
it's very hard for me
to talk about this
work in under an hour.
This is a diagram of
some kind of order
I tried to give to this project.
I'm not even trying to
get into that for you.
But to clarify
that a little bit,
if you look at the top row, you
see body, land, water, power,
void.
Those sort of became subjects
that helped me organize this
into something--
to five chapters.
And so this is becoming
a series of five sort
of large-scale video works.
And then there's kind of a
trickle down of other output
that's wall works and sculptures
that kind of can fit anywhere
within this.
They're kind of
responding to, I would
say, their material
output in relation
to ideas in the videos.
But they're not objects
that are strictly fixed,
any one of these chapters.
So currently, I completed the
sun or power chapter, "A Smeary
Spot."
I just completed
"Living Room," which
is the piece that's at
the New Museum, which
is the chapter on the body.
And I'm partway into
"Leave No Trace,"
which is the land chapter.
And what you'll see in
the gallery next door
is an audio project
that's actually
the soundtrack for that work.
So having an experiment in which
I tried to make the soundtrack
before I made the work--
I'm not sure that's a good idea.
But we'll find out.
So I started with the
premise that I wanted
to make a science fiction.
And my reason for being
interested in science fiction
is I wanted to work between
fantasy and politics.
I also am interested in
both utopia and dystopia.
So for me, utopia is,
what's possible is
what you can imagine.
And dystopia is,
what's happening
is worse than you can imagine.
So I'm kind of flux between
those two worlds in this work.
That means that there
are times when--
well, let me just say that I
think that utopia is important,
in terms of I believe all
political change stems
from utopic visions.
You have to think much bigger
than what you can accomplish.
And that's the beginning step
to like moving progressively
in kind of any
break with what we
know is the sort of form
of politics or society
at any point.
And for me, the
dystopic is a way
to reflect on all
of the crap that's
going on at the same time
that I'm making this work.
Speculative present--
so this work
is set in what I call
a speculative present.
That means that I'm really
interested in the now.
I'm interested in
the idea that the now
is always becoming both the past
and the future simultaneously.
So it's a highly active space.
Also, I think if you want
to change the future,
you have to change the now.
So aesthetically, the way this
is set up is it doesn't have--
it's a science
fiction that doesn't--
it's not a 2001 Odyssey.
We don't have slick, futuristic
machines, and spaceships,
and things like that.
I'm interested in like
that the future is--
I like to think of the
future like a iPhone
with a cracked face.
You have technology,
but you don't
have enough money to fix it.
OK?
It seems a lot more practical.
All right, acting agents, this
is another principle for me,
is that the performers
in this work
are not performing subjects,
or characters, or nouns even.
They might be nouns,
actually, sometimes.
But the performer's
actually actions.
They're phenomena.
They're agents of change.
They're symbolizing various
sort of metaphysical aspects
of the world.
And I'll explain
them more when I get
to the different acting agents.
But that also means that
I don't see the performers
as protagonists.
So it's an inversion of
thinking, cinematic thinking.
I actually see the
site, or the stage,
or whatever location I'm
working in as the protagonist.
So in the first film, that's
the desert, or the black box
theater.
In the second one, it's
this building in which
the whole piece is set.
And the last thing I want
to talk about to preface
this is, matter is what does.
So that is, a thinking in
which all matter is animate.
It's an idea of acknowledging
that all matter is constantly
changing.
There's nothing
consistent about matter.
And so if we start to look kind
of fundamentally at the tiniest
parts of our being as
constantly changing,
the things that we see as
fixed are really just ways
that we organize the world.
And so this is a little
bit about entering
an alternate space of accepting
that the order of things
is not as we perceive
them inherently.
Oh, and queer--
OK, one more.
So queer, for me, is
something that I would
like to sort of divorce from.
I don't want to divorce
it from its history
as a word from the homosexual
movement and narrative.
I think it's important that
it hold onto that history.
But I think it's
not really useful.
That's not a useful
anchor in its meaning now
or in the future.
And by that, I mean I
have friends who are--
a trans woman and
a trans man dating.
Are they homosexuals?
No, but they're queer.
There's a lot of other
examples I could use.
But I think that
what I want to think
about queer as is a
space of what I'm calling
un-assimilated difference.
And then it also
becomes, maybe, a space
for a more kind of
intersectional thinking
about what a queer body
is, and that it's not
fixed to your sexual
orientation inherently.
And there's a lot of
un-assimilated bodies
in the world--
and that we might
advocate for that,
or champion that as a
better way of moving
through the world instead
of assimilation, which
is how most things work.
OK, "A Smeary Spot," here we go.
So the installation
is a four-channel.
There's three large
channels, which
are like 7 foot screens,
7 by 12 foot screens.
And then there's a small monitor
at the end, which you can see.
And that cycles
through the credits.
The credits are kept
separate, so that the film
can run as a seamless loop.
And also because the credits
are not just everyone
who worked on the film.
But they also carry
some like kind
of footnotes that maybe give
you some of the information
that I was just giving.
It's different than the
information I just gave you,
but there's a lot
of clues about how
to read the work that is in the
way that I wrote the credits.
So I'm treating the credits
kind of as their own piece.
This is similar.
I just brightened
this one up, so you
can see it a little better.
But also, the three
screams are installed
at like a 10 degree angle in the
space, so that they actually--
this is a very long space
that was installed in,
sort of narrow corridor.
That angle in the wall
makes the work kind
of hold the space
in a way that's
very different than when
projections happen on a wall
or on a flat surface.
They become sort of bodies
or presences of their own.
And I'm really
interested in the way
video is and can be sculptural.
Also, the seating
is an office chairs.
Part of that is there's
office chairs that
show up in the video.
But also, I'm interested
in this like--
they kind of imply
labor, but labor that
happens while you're seated.
And I want you to be
a very active viewer.
There's also six
channels of sound.
And the sound moves from screen
to screen, or brackets you.
It's very active.
I actually hope that someone is
motivated to move with the work
to a certain degree, even if
it's just their attention.
In this installation,
there's also--
I've installed it twice.
And there's been two different
sculptures like this.
And so this is one.
It's a process that I've
been using for a while, where
I've been casting sand.
So that's sand that
I dyed that's black.
Those are the
sandbags, that are also
cast into it-- the white bits.
And then the top
chunk is concrete.
So it's got this
kind of strange kind
of strata sort of cavernous
natural form meeting
this industrial sort
of building bit--
industrial building bit, yes.
And ensconced in that is what--
may be hard to see-- but it
you can see kind of the
spine of the office chair.
So I was sort of interested in--
the chair is this object
of mobility, or movement,
or fluidity in
the room, and then
this kind of fossilizing of that
object in this sort of Earth
monument piece.
And those are the
wheels sticking out
of the top of the work.
This is another
version of this, which
is the chair has been taken
apart a little bit more.
And it's displayed
on pedestals that
are made out of
the packing boxes
that the chairs were shipped in.
And then the work is
actually cast inside the box.
So the shape of the work is--
you can see some of the relief,
I think, of the cardboard
in the sand casting.
All right, the other thing
that's on display in this work
is this poster, which is
the script for the work.
And part of the reason I gave
the script is because what I've
done is collected a
lot of texts that I
was reading that influenced
the making of this work.
And I wove the text together.
But also, they're being
recited in the work
by different acting agents.
One thing I had an issue
with is some of the texts
were coming from
like theory texts.
And so they're terribly dull
to listen to someone recite.
So I took some liberties to
change some of the language
to make it, let's say,
readable, reciteable,
without changing the
meaning too much.
And then the other
thing that was
important to me, is a lot of
theory texts and other texts,
when they refer to humans, they
usually use the word he, right?
So it's often gendered.
So in any place where
gender shows up,
I've gone in and
made it first person.
So you can see it says, like, "I
became" in that line up there.
But it was important to me, that
if I'm taking other people's
words, and especially
if I'm altering them,
that it was revealed in some
way in the installation.
This work is set
in two locations.
One part of it takes place
in a black box theater.
The theater is something I came
to after being in the desert.
And I was thinking a
lot about the desert
as a kind of negative
space, thinking a lot
about the fullness
of that absence
that you feel when you're
in a space that big.
Also, and a lot of ideas about
the chapter that I will develop
about the void started
to come into play, where
I was thinking, in
this site of absences
is, again, like sort
of the most potential.
And the theater became a
really good analogy for that.
Because one, on film,
the black box theater
dissipates into sort of nothing.
Because you can
give the illusion
of emerging from nothing.
And also that the theater is
a space of constant becoming.
It's always making
and unmaking itself.
And the other thing that's
central in the theater space
is this waste pile.
So this waste pile was inspired
by a quote by Jack Smith.
Jack Smith was a filmmaker
and performance artist
prominent in the '50s and '60s,
a queer icon of sorts, for me,
certainly.
So he imagined a
society where the dump
is the central site of economic
and intellectual exchange.
So this is really a
homage to that idea.
And everything that happens
in the theater is built from
or goes back into this pile.
And then the desert--
so I can't give you
the whole background
story of getting to the desert.
But let's just say, I fell
in love with the Utah desert.
And while I was there,
one of the big things
that emerged for me
was I found myself
on a lot of public lands.
And this also became a
kind of foundational thing
for how I was going to
think about this work.
I guess maybe I should
give a little background
on public lands.
People know what
public lands are?
Yes, no?
Yes.
Do we have time for that?
How about this, research
public lands if you don't know.
I probably don't have enough
time to tell you all about it.
I'm so sorry.
Anyway, so public
lands, in a brief,
though, is a site
where you can--
it's an unlike private
property, or reservation land,
or national forests.
There's not really a sign of
when you enter or you exit it.
The rules are not obvious.
It's protected by the
Bureau of Land Management
et cetera, et cetera.
So you can kind of exist there.
It's kind of what I like to
think of as a socialist anomaly
in our capitalist society.
And while it has a
lot of problems--
I'm not going to get into
the real political problems
of public lands--
it proposed for me one of
the utopic ideas for me,
which is, if we unfix
ourselves from property,
what kind of society or what
kind of body emerges from that?
And quickly, this
is the map of Utah.
Everything that is
yellow is public lands.
So 70% of Utah is public lands.
So there's massive
swaths of space.
Also, when you're
in public lands,
it's really like feels endless.
Another thing I ran into while
I was out there is Lake Powell.
Lake Powell-- I think this
is kind of obvious just
by looking at this image.
But it's very surreal looking.
And of course, I was
attracted to the surrealism
of much of the
landscape there, which
is why I started to stage
this science fiction there.
But I, later on, discovered
that it was a damned canyon.
And so the reason it
looks the way that it does
is because it's essentially
like a full glass of water.
There's no real
edge to this water.
There's no particulation.
It's just these sort
of rocks emerging out.
And then when you dive
into the water, of course,
it's this canyon
that's down there.
And so when I discovered
this, it became like--
well, it's deeply sad.
You have to imagine,
then, that there's
this tremendous world
under there that's
been submerged by this decision
for intervention into the land.
So that has actually--
I'm diverging from this
project for a second here,
which is, that led me to
doing a series of works
that you're actually going
to see in the Radcliffe show.
And these were taken
by Todd Nichols.
The black and white photos were
taken by Todd Nichols in 1956.
He's a photographer.
He went to Glen Canyon,
which was the name of it
it became Lake Powell.
And that's the Colorado River
that runs through Glen Canyon.
And he went and documented
and archived that landscape.
And so I made these works
where I ripped images out
of his catalog, and made these
sort of liquid interventions
of either kind of
tracing what would
seem like the new line of
water, and what has disappeared.
Or sometimes, it's just
more aggressive kind
of ejaculations on the page.
But this sort of
notion of obscuring,
or a mark of that
kind of loss of what's
happened to that landscape.
I'm going to play a
clip just quickly.
This is going to be a
scene that moves us.
Part of why I'm
playing this scene
is it starts with Matana
Roberts on saxophone.
It will move to
Mother Flawless, who
plays a clairvoyant psyche--
and by that, I mean mind.
So again, we're talking about
the metaphysical character--
and who is reciting a
quote from Karen Barad's,
"What is the measure of
nothingness, infinity,
virtuality, and justice."
And then it moves
into the desert.
And another thing
to pay attention
to is really unfortunate,
is that I have to show you
three screens at once.
But these are supposed
to be 7 foot screens.
So you'll see things that--
the scale is so
important to this work,
being able to really
be inside the work.
And you'll see that insects, and
humans, and things are scaled
at the same scale and whatever.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[SAXOPHONE PLAYING]
- Nothingness, a void,
an absence of matter,
a blank page, utter silence,
no thing, no thought,
no awareness, complete
insensibility.
So we utter some words
about nothingness.
What's there to say?
Probably began
how could anything
be said about nothing without
violating its very nature,
perhaps, even its
conditions of possibility?
And have we not
already said too much
simply in pronouncing its name?
Perhaps, we should let the
emptiness speak for itself.
[THUNDER RUMBLING]
[RAIN FALLING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[BIRDS CALLING]
[BUZZING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- People tell you that
they'd rather stay and take
their chances, literally
abandon their property
and live elsewhere.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[BUZZING]
[INSECTS CHIRPING]
- We're to bring you live
coverage from the offices
of Emergency
Management [INAUDIBLE].
- It was distance
and power [INAUDIBLE]
[END PLAYBACK]
- OK, I really
cut you off there.
But we must move on.
So the tiny character you
see there in the center--
little orange jump suit--
that's a character I
call our acting agent.
That's the obsurveyer.
So I was thinking
a lot about land
surveying as a first stage in
kind of monetizing or dividing
up land.
But this character spends their
time in the desert observing.
And they also kind of perform
being the camera in a way.
Because they're always
holding the camera.
And as you noticed, like, the
camera on the other screen
is being adjusted.
It's sort of more alive
than the landscape
in a way at that moment.
The other thing that
occurs in the desert
is we follow two, what
I call, free radicals.
And that is a pun on both the
electron-seeking molecule--
like an unstable molecule
that's useful for modes
of combustion and other
things that free radicals are
good at--
and also, kind of a radicalized
body, or a agent of protest,
like somebody who's
embodying that.
And I like this
idea that something
could be both like kind
of human and molecule.
So they spend a lot of their
time collecting material waste.
The waste that exists in a kind
of focused way in the black box
theater kind of exist
on their bodies.
They are kind of always
collecting, and loading up,
and unloading as they move
through the landscape.
Here they're collecting
water from a leaky pipe.
And water becomes also--
I mentioned this
before about the water.
But one of the big things
for me about the dam
was [SIGHS] just thinking
about water that flows
and water that's controlled,
and things that flows
and things that are controlled.
And so then the leak
becomes really important.
Because it's this place where,
even when we try and control
things, things escape.
And this is sort
of a dance sequence
that, for me, is
like a kind of take
on flagging, which is
part of queer culture--
is historically used to identify
that someone, one, was queer,
and two, what they
might want from you,
or what you might
want from them.
So I brought two dancers
with me, Niv Acosta, and Jen
Rosenblit, to the desert.
And you might
actually be flagging
like the sun, and the
water, and the atmosphere--
like, that the
fighting might occur
not as a human interaction,
but as a kind of way
of visibility or engagement
with an environment.
There's also a sequence
in which they measure.
It's kind of a dance
sequence also--
a little more abstract--
where they're kind of
moving through the landscape
and measuring the
space with their body.
And then, in the theater,
what's happening in the theater,
most often, is these
series of recitations
of this text that kind of
hold the work together.
So I'm going to play
one more for you.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[FOOTSTEPS]
[EXHALES]
[HEARTBEATS]
- There was a wall.
It did not look important.
It was built of uncut
stone, roughly mortared.
[OBJECT FALLING ON THE GROUND]
We're across the roadway.
Instead of having a
gate, it degenerated
into a mere geometry, a line.
And I did have a boundary.
But the idea was important.
It was real.
Like all walls, it was
ambiguous, two-faced
What was inside and what
was outside depended
which side of it you were on.
[SMACKS LIPS]
[BREATHING DEEPLY]
[END PLAYBACK]
- So I extracted that from the
three channels, by the way.
So there's other
channels that are active.
I just wanted you to get
the cinematic scale, a feel,
for the work.
So in that scene--
so once we move
into the theater,
the free radicals
are all wearing
what I call activist drag, which
means a black T-shirt, jeans,
and combat boots.
[LAUGHS]
And then anyone
who is reciting--
any time there's a
recitation going on,
it's kind of really focused
on a single activity,
or gesture, and the language.
And so I'm interested in
the way this kind of working
with a certain material
and the language
sort of make its own meaning.
So that lipstick starts to
have a lot more layers to it
when we're talking about
boundaries, and lines,
and things, right?
This is another scene where the
action is pushing all the air
out of an air mattress.
There's a lot of camping
gear throughout this work.
You can imagine why.
We started out in the desert.
It continues on throughout.
And also thinking a
lot about nomadic--
like, the material
of our contemporary,
like the commerce
around nomad-ism
in contemporary culture.
And this is another scene.
Jen Rosenblit does this
incredible job of caking--
it starts out kind of
like a light mud mask,
and quickly turns
into this kind of--
she becomes completely
ensconced in the mud,
and actually, sort of
becomes the landscape.
And this becomes an
important thing for me,
is looking for ways in which
the work in the theater
can move us back
into the desert.
Because at one point when
I was working on this work,
I was really like, oh, my god.
I have like this stark black
and the brightness of--
everything felt really
binary all of the sudden
between these two worlds.
And so I started to develop some
of this visual material that
helped move me between
these two worlds.
This is the shapeshifter.
So this is her in her natural
state of perpetual becoming.
So she's getting ready always.
Played by [? Marcelo ?]
[? Gutierrez. ?] And one of her
tasks is taking care of
this Chelsea Manning jacket,
which she does kind of in
a loving and fetish-y kind
of way, like stroking
and caring for it.
And Chelsea Manning's jacket
shows up in the second piece
as well.
But what I'm kind of
interested in with Chelsea--
and this is kind of
this way that the now
shows up in this work.
So there's always
a kind of layer
of real political event
merging with this kind
of strange fantastical space.
But Manning, for me, is
another kind of leak, right?
So it's not only the information
leaks, but also a leaky body,
a body that's not fitting, or
is transitioning, et cetera.
So the shapeshifter, when
she's not in her natural state,
becomes other things.
In this case, this is kind of
a remake of a famous painting,
for anyone who's not
familiar with art history--
very canonical work.
Well, there we go.
Olympia-- if you haven't
seen it, there it is.
Back to this version
on air mattresses.
In this scene, there's a
recitation from [INAUDIBLE]--
I don't know if I'm
ever saying that right--
"Screwball Asses."
So it's kind of taking this
vision of the prostitute
through Marcelo's body.
And the text kind of speaks
of the virtues of womanhood
through a vision of
the lesbian body.
Anyway, you can imagine
where that goes.
OK, so the other.
Character is Aunt Be/e.
This is Aunt Be/e.
This is a shapeshifter
as Aunt Be/e.
So Aunt Be/e, that's B-E
slash E, as in being, or a--
OK, you get it.
And that's because this
character is also--
so Aunt Be/e is performing
as reproductive labor.
And this is what
a little insight
in how I develop the character,
is I was thinking about bees.
Because that's a really
obvious idea about labor.
And I found this
fantastic photo of a bee.
And that got me to creating the
yellow dust on [? Neyland ?]
for this scene.
Now I'm not interested
in, when people
watch my work, that they,
like, get all of that.
I'm interested in you
having an experience,
and that there's
something kind of--
I'm into manipulating
people, actually.
I want to seduce you with
a certain amount of image
and sound, so that
you kind of believe me
whatever I put in front of you.
And so you could unpack this
work with that level of detail.
But I'm sort of more
interested in that you just
become kind of absorbed
in the sort of world
that I create for you.
And anyway, so
reproductive labor
is set with the
task of operating
a Xerox machine and a juicer.
The juicer I'm
interested in, because it
changes a solid to a liquid.
It also has kind of
a component of waste
that happens that's really
beautiful, and then also
for the aesthetic reasons.
So this also allowed me to
create the scene in which we
get something that's very
similar to the strata
in the desert.
And it also became like
a way to segue into--
and I was also
interested in this one
with the sort of overflow
excess that occurs.
So the exhibition "Shabby But
Thriving" at the New Museum
is the second in the series.
It's the video that's
based around the body.
A lot of the way this
work is being developed
is sort of with the resources
I can glean to make it.
So through the
residency at the museum,
they offer you to
work in the building
next door to the New Museum,
which is this old Bowery
building that's dilapidated.
And they're actually going
to be rent renovating it
into the New Museum.
But that's a future story.
So what I started to
think, I was, like, OK,
how am I going from the
desert to the theater?
Does it make sense
to be in a building?
Does that even make
sense to be in a city?
So then I got really
interested in the idea
that the building
was its own body,
and that we could do this whole
piece sort of hermetically
sealed in this building.
We would never leave this space.
And it would be this
sort of internal world,
and bodies within
antibodies that would occur.
So the insulation
is set up with what
is a kind of quasi-living room.
There's a carpet that's
pretty filthy at this point,
because it's a light
colored carpet.
So it attracts everyone
who walks through it.
There's this couch, which
is kind of excerpted.
I'll go to this scene.
So there's a scene--
there's three children that
occupy couches with underglow.
They're kind of
like planets, right?
And so this object in the
room is a gutted couch.
There's a scene in which
the couches become gutted,
ultimately.
And then it's propped up on
these cast dirt bags of soil.
And that's developed from
one of the scenes which
you can kind of see here--
this couch on the
left, actually--
which was built around the idea
that each one of the children
is a different celestial
body, AKA a dwarf planet.
So that's Pluto.
And the dirt bags
are kind of, for me,
reminiscent of the narrative
behind the name of Pluto,
which is, one, the
god of the underworld.
But more importantly,
it can be also seen
as like a mineral, resources,
and the keeper of the earth,
and soil, and stuff like that.
Anyway, so the
seats of the couch
have been replaced with
these bags of dirt.
And so that's where
this sculpture
object skeleton thing developed
from that's in the room.
And also, what you see
here is you've got--
I'm going to go to
this one again--
a false wall that
was built. So you've
got it sort of raw,
drywall, false wall.
I was interested in the sort
of exposed architecture.
And then what the
second screen is
a actually a piece
of drywall that's
been leaned against the wall.
So you have these
kind of elements
of a building being built
within this environment
of the installation.
All right, so there are these
children, which I have already
explained are--
they occupy what is
the living room space.
And the living room is
also called the psyche.
These are things that are
also noted in the credits,
like they were in
the last piece.
And I got interested in
the idea of dwarf planets,
not only because the
children are small--
I like really easy connections.
I'm really interested
in easy connections.
But there's something about the
dwarf planet, especially Pluto,
which you know was kicked
out of the solar system.
I'm interested in this idea
of what's an acceptable--
when are you a planet?
When are you on a planet?
It's the kind of
othering situation
I think is fascinating.
And then the children
all have jumpsuits
that match their couches.
And so the couches are, of
course, bodies unto themselves.
They're hosts for bodies.
That's how we hang out
with them, in general.
But I think, in this
case, the children
kind of operate in a quasi-space
of they are of the couch.
And I was also interest
in working with children,
because I was interested in sort
of a state of pre-definition.
Kids also sit somewhere
between reality and fantasy
very easily.
And so what they perform--
at one point, this
child who's taking care
of a fish tank and a fish--
which also, for me, symbolizes
the desert in this work.
You can see the tank is kind
of like half full of water.
And there's this big red rock.
And there's a lot of
focus on this tank.
So I like that the
desert could show up,
but it would be in the
kind of innermost space
within this work.
This child ends up performing,
caring for the fish,
but also becoming the fish,
and plays a fish out of water,
kind of called convulsing
at some point on the floor.
This one, [? Erris, ?] is set
with the task of fly swatting.
I was thinking a
lot about violence
throughout the whole
making of this piece.
And I'm really interested
in micro-violence,
or the small things, the things
that we overlook as violence,
like killing a fly.
Most of us don't think
twice about that.
So I'm interested in kind of
amplifying small things often.
In this case, the room starts
sort of speaking to the child.
And it's not clear if the child
is chasing a fly or the room
itself also.
And then this one, Pluto.
Pluto ends up performing
like a bird of prey,
and does its beautiful
scene of like kind
of squawking as a
bird in relation
to this fish in the tank.
And that's another scene just
showing the bags of soil.
So the Manning jacket
shows up again here,
and is worn by Keyon Gaskin,
another dancer performer--
and again, to bring the
weight of the leaky body
into this scene, which
takes place in a stairwell.
So another one of
the scenes that
moves throughout the whole
work is we move from the top
to the bottom of the building
through this stairwell
throughout the whole work.
And in that process,
there's kind
of just this movement of
the destructed couches,
and all this sort of-- so
the garbage, again, shows up.
Waste shows up again
as a kind of movement
from and through the building.
And it's also very
much like a descent.
The whole thing is moving
downwards in the building.
So I think of that as kind
of a movement of mouth
to anus, or like a process of
moving through the entire body.
Because it's a
two-screen piece, you
see this descent
happening simultaneously.
Ms. Manning is one
of the characters.
And the pregnant
backpacker is the other.
So this, for me,
was this feeling.
When I was thinking about all
of this like weight bearing
and bodies that hold
symbolically and in reality
social and political
weight, I thought of--
with the pregnant
body, that's already
like a physical kind of weight.
And then I was like, OK, we'll
throw a backpack on that,
and make it just
like this kind of
counter weighted
impossibility on top
of the weight of everything
else that's going
to be taken down the stairwell.
And that's entering
the basement,
which we'll get to in a minute.
But then there's
another scene, which
I'm just going to do
this, so you can actually
see both characters,
Keyon and [? Steiner. ?]
This is the bathroom,
or the kidneys.
This is the detox tub talks.
And they spend their time
in the bathroom discussing--
mostly, they're discussing
language, and words,
and whether or how words are
functional or non functional.
And then that leads
into a conversation
about needing to name a
new party, a lesbian party.
Turns out it's a
lesbian dance party.
It could be any party, though.
And in the end, the
result is that they
get to calling the party lies.
But this is maybe the
most humorous section.
Everything's a little dark.
But this is, maybe, the lighter
part of the work in that way.
The other thing I
want to say here
is that this scene is a
remake of Death of Marat.
Again, I'm interested in
co-opting the canon here.
And what I was interested
in the story of Murat
is that he was working as--
most of you probably already
know the story of Murat--
but was part of the
French Revolution,
and was a writer, activist,
as you would call it,
and was killed.
The scene that you see
there in the painting
was killed by a woman
from the Bourgeois class.
So I didn't want
anyone to kill anyone.
Or I was interested
in the way that death
could happen that was not
obvious forms of violence,
like guns, and
knives, and things.
Again, but talking about
violence on the body.
So both of them are suffering
from different ailments
that are not really
considered ailments.
So we have Keyon,
who's suffering
from persistent
microaggressions, which
is the case of the band-aids.
And [? Steiner ?] is suffering
from economic toxicity,
which ultimately, will
lead to her demise
through a bloody nose.
And then we have
the painting scene.
And I will end on
this high note.
So the film ends
in the basement.
And this scene was built around
a couple of different ideas.
First of all, I was thinking of
the basement as the place where
the furnace is, where
there's the source of heat,
this sort of generative
space of the basement--
or that the basement is one
of the more generative spaces
within a building, or
within the body, then--
and that, as a source of power,
let's say, within the building,
I wanted to introduce
synchronized dancing
into that space.
So I was thinking both as
the way bodies are organized
through synchronized dancing--
and that can be both an
analogy of like a machine
or in a kind of protest, right?
But the kind of choreography,
I worked with the great,
wonderful, young dancer,
[? Nick ?] [? Kaye, ?]
to choreograph this scene.
But the whole thing
was shot in the dark,
was only illuminated
by headlamps.
So also, all lighting kind
of moves with the bodies.
And then these
T-shirts, which were all
extracted from the
current, or most recent,
political campaigns.
So they're the last words
in everyone's campaign.
So "her," "again,"
or "bust," and then
the "no," which
is just something
I've been thinking a lot about.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Give me that word.
That word.
Give me that word
Give me that word.
Give me those lies.
Lies.
[INAUDIBLE]
And you watch.
We're ready.
And you [INAUDIBLE].
[END PLAYBACK]
Hopefully that language
is now liberated.
And thank you, everyone.
[MUSIC PLAYING]